I have absolutely no idea how to enter
this other than it's long overdue yes so
folks welcome to council of geeks my
partner liz is joining me hello everyone
and what I did god like him I don't know
how long ago now when I did my ranking
of my favorite angel characters from
Joss Whedon's show angel I said that I
was putting off doing the Buffy I
character top-10 because I wanted to do
something special that special thing was
to have Liz on with me I should take a
second go ahead I won't but I should so
she's she's actually come to this with
her own little addition which is that we
have our top tens written on index cards
neither of us knows our top tens or our
rankings so these will be both of our
we're going to go from you know ten up
to one and talk about these characters
and as we name them when they're on our
list we'll talk about what we like about
them there's a pretty good chance that
we're gonna wow there's we're definitely
going to have some of the same
characters on these lists possibly in
different rankings so I'm gonna try and
hold off saying what we really like
about them until they come up on our own
list
Oh about some of these characters on the
back well yes I know so it so I don't
want you to have to like reference see
here's the difference this is the back
of my card these are the backs of her
cards alright and what I invited her to
do this the first thing she did was
borrow about half of my Buffy DVD boxset
so that she can re-watch
you can rewatch and confirm rankings I
only like to I didn't do the whole
seasons I only did key episodes and only
on certain characters where I was unsure
that that was their true ranking and I
confirmed for most of it I wasn't sure
for a couple of my top characters so I
had to figure out where they fell all
right all right so you know lazy geek
librarian can you spot the difference I
think you can so all right we'll start
with our number 10 oh and you also have
a prediction you wanted to make oh yes
my prediction is basically we will not
have the same number too
but we will have the same number one
yeah my prediction well we'll see if
there's I'm not gonna predict further
than that cuz that's a lot something for
me we're going to start with our number
Ten's oh really okay okay so on yeah
Anya is she on your leg she is not okay
so arm yeah um so I really like how
blunt and literal she is and I enjoy her
banter with Xander she's got an
interesting background and I wish they
had kind of followed it up on the I mean
they mentioned it and did a couple
flashbacks her vengeance demon days but
I would have liked to have seen more of
that um she's fun like I like her quite
a bit again I'm like tenth I I liked
Anya she didn't quite make my list I
think part of my thing I like her
dynamic with a lot of the characters I
think part of the thing for me is it was
very she's one of those characters where
it's very obvious that they hadn't
planned on making her a major part of
the cast and they kind of reworked her
as they went along because like there's
there's a like I remember when she had
her flashback to like her pre vengeance
demon days and they basically try to
establish no she was always like this
even before she was a demon which was a
bit of an internal wreck on over they I
kind of justified her acting the way she
was because she'd been a demon
so long she forgot what it was like to
be a person and that's what I kind of
mean they kind of made it they kind of
made up the rules and her
characterization as they went along okay
well keep in mind in terms of me really
like sitting down and watching all the
episodes of Buffy that was like more
than 10 years ago so it's fair it's been
a while remembering all those bits and
things like that oh I will also say I
think she does the blunt and thing and
like kind of you know being you know
telling other characters off better than
Cordy does because she does it she never
seems like a mean girl like Cordy does
Cordy is definitely the mean girl
Cordelia is also not on my list
Cordelia is not on my list sorry Cordy I
like her okay she works better on the
engine she did work better on it so my
number 10 was Tara and Tara Tara is just
sweet yeah Tara is just wonderful and
sweet and she doesn't get hired because
I mean she's this is gonna sound awful
but there isn't a ton of depth to her
she kind of is what she appears to be
but what she appears to be is very nice
and I like her there and I like her
presence and I like seeing her kind of
come out of her shell a little bit over
time you will see her on my list she's
significantly higher come on
okay good to know I'm supposed to wait
to talk to her yeah you'll get to talk
about her when you when you get to her
okay so we'll get to number nine ready
okay here we go we get to both talk
about Jonathan now okay um so I love the
episode superstar first of all so much
fun he's just one of those great like
background characters that you don't
really notice until he's highlighted in
certain episodes and again like it's
just it's superstars just a lot of fun
because here you
have this afterthought of the character
that's being obsessed over and worships
and he just it was an impressive acting
turn cuz I mean it was very put on it
was very overdone but that was an
impressive amount of swagger for a guy
who was just so it's kinda like up to
that point I kind of that's is that
Danny Danny strong I had like this great
career after in terms of screenwriting
oh yeah he has become quite quite a
prolific screenwriter yeah I mean I'm
just yeah he's um you will not see any
of the other trio on my list
so not a chance definitely not worn you
out see Warren I feel like is a separate
thing because Warren you have to rank as
a villain and I sort of well I have some
villainous characters yeah but I mean
like if I if word ever show up on a list
of mine it would be as a villain that's
kind of a different criteria even a good
villain I'm sorry and you're better
hating on Warren here Andrew would not
show up on any list I would ever oh you
really hate Andy I contemplated him but
I'm like he's kind of annoying
I might not hate him so much if they
hadn't killed Jonathan in favor of
keeping Andrew I'm really bitter about
that that is fair that being said that
with my other note I thought he made a
really good vessel for the first and was
mirrors it was one of the better ones
that a lot of them the other one I
really liked adds a vessel up for the
first was like Cassie or whatever she
was good she was really pointy I should
have mentioned spoilers but we're
ranking the characters from a show
that's that is I don't even know how
many years old now so yeah um I also
like think he's really kind of sweetly
earnest but obviously his character
becomes very misguided at very point
various points in the show yes up with
the trio but yeah he's just great he's
great an ear shot which I had to revisit
cuz I hadn't seen it I don't think ever
fully ten years ago and I knew there was
like a school shooting in that and
he was involved lots of spoilers by the
way and I was like oh god I'm gonna hate
him for this but it was never that he
was actually gonna shoot his classmates
so I was like okay can still like javac
and Jonathan can still be in the list if
he had been more of a prominent
character I wouldn't be surprised that I
would have ranked him higher I like he's
always with him
he he was he was a great he was
literally just a background extra but he
was great just they they picked a great
character to eat to highlight more and
to expand later on mm-hmm yep um yeah
he's probably the most minor of my
characters on earth list I feel like
he's the the Buffy equivalent to Gunther
in friends yeah yep okay so number eight
yeah here we go ah I contemplated him
but he's not on my list
oz is not on my list okay you can go
first
okay well the the mayor I'm not sure
he's necessarily my favorite villain but
I absolutely love him as a character I
love a guy who has this very you know
this very sort of kind of square you
know just wants to do right by the
community guy but well what I love about
that is it's not really a facade he's
actually like that
at the same time he is plotting to
basically kill everybody because
generally you know you'd have that in
character and they would you know get
away from the public eye and they'd turn
it off and they'd go out and he never
does that he's the same he's the same Oh
golly shucks gee guy when he's planning
to Massacre people his constituent I
love him and I love his dynamic with
faith I was just gonna say that that was
one of my favorite things about him cuz
I do believe he genuinely cares about
her yeah absolutely and she she so
desperately needs like a father figure
or someone who
actually light pays to attention I'm
pulling you over you're leaning that way
I don't want to lose you from the shop
so okay okay my house um I have the
least amount of notes on him which is
absolutely appropriate so he's in a band
I mean he's just cool he's just so
low-key and mellow and everything which
I like that they contrast that with
having him be aware of you know like
it's a kind of a nice contrast you know
that like he's a crazed werewolf Kato a
couple nights a month yeah he's like the
chillest dude on the planet yeah also he
has a crossbow in one episode I hadn't
put that on my notes but I want to just
point that out that just makes him
cooler obviously fan of the crossbow
well yeah I mean I watched a little bit
of The Walking Dead and Daryl with his
crossbow you know across those they're
always cool
I bailed on walking dead before he
showed up so he was in the first couple
of episodes
no it wasn't he was not in season one at
all no Merle his brother was in season
one really I can't remember anyways um
so yeah I he's just a cool dude he's
mellow he's I mean he also great-tasting
girlfriends he does have that I think
excuse me I think part of the thing with
Oz is I feel like he never had a proper
exit from the show he had two of them
and neither of them were very to come
back yeah so I yeah honestly if it
wasn't for that he might have cracked my
top ten but I feel like he just kind of
went out with such a whimper that it
kind of dings the whole thing to a
little bit which honestly might also be
part of the reason I ins not on my list
cuz I don't like what happens to her in
the series finale either I don't know
what it is with Joshua and try trying
for the non heroic deaths of characters
the only time it's worked was the
Avengers when he killed Coulson that was
the only time he it's worked but he does
it a lot
regardless yeah you should treat the
significant
there's better yeah violently I've had
to move on number seven
okay here we go of the Slayer okay go
ahead
okay so I have grown to like her more
revisiting these episodes she really
annoyed me in my 20s because she went
haha
self-righteous she is okay so she's
hired okay um and now that I'm older
than her I can kind of see I can kind of
get behind her vulnerability and her
quirkiness more I have always like been
protective of her even when I didn't
really like her if there was a character
that Bobby Lee um no fellow blond
solidarity right there it was just like
like and I get this way about certain
characters I'm like I don't really like
them but if someone I don't know or
really like it's you know like going
after them I'm like oh I'm gonna get you
know and so I feel that for her and I
think I always did since that
vulnerability about her and she has just
a feet and a job and at-at like tasks
that no one should have no one no one
wants this and I think I feel the burden
of that more and I think part in I think
honestly Sarah Michelle Gellar is really
underrated as an actress
um I mean that's a that's a series and
that's a big meaty role to carry for
seven years
Jenn's I think she does it well and
there's so much to the character um I
really like when she smiles like it's
just she lights up and she gets to do it
not very often at all and it's just the
show did right by ending on her starting
to smile that was that was actually the
right moment end
show and yeah and she there is kind of
like a lovable quirkiness to her and
some of her little quips are so cute in
her little her I mean she is a very
attractive girl but she's got her
awkwardness and I yeah she's played that
off well the it's like she's naturally
pretty but she also doesn't have time to
deal with the fact that she's pretty
she's got a lot on her plate and the
fact that like like I love that I mean
it's so sad but the episode where her
mother dies she just carries that so
well are you really like liking how
sarah michelle gellar plays ER which i
never really think of her that much as
an actress outside at buffy but like the
more I think about it I'm like no you
did well so so faith I'm gonna yep very
would have landed higher if I had not
made a conscious choice to die to
divorce what happens to her from an
angel from her placement on this list
because I think in many ways her arc
gets completed in another show that's
him
especially it's been specially from her
revival in in season four you could look
at what happened to her in season three
and consider that more or less complete
but her revival in season four works it
doesn't feel like we're rehashing old
stuff but then that goes off and that
all gets dealt with in another show so I
don't get to cap an idol and I love all
that I love her
trying to save angel and at the same
time like really needing him to help her
get through her own history in her own
darkness but I can't count any of that
here and that's the reason she's not
higher so in terms of her function in
Buffy itself
she's primarily there as a villain her
redemption story is almost entirely in
another show what about her in season
seven she comes back in season seven but
again her arc has been finished she just
kind of comes back
and is one more piece of the puzzle I I
can't it if you only watch Buffy and you
never see her stuff in angel you will
feel like wow I missed a lot of what
happened to her between when she left in
season born when she came back 2007
that's true that said I like faith a lot
I like Eliza Eliza Dushku quite a bit I
think she is and she is really good at
that sort of angry energy that faith has
behind almost everything she ever does
and I also loved a few times that the
shell cracks a little bit around
characters like the mayor or sometimes
when she's alone like you know coming
off of taking over
Buffy's body when she gets her own body
back she just bolts and you really get
the sense that she's really deeply
ashamed and she plays it all really well
but it's just it's because that I'm it
seems unfair to call it a missing piece
because it's not really but it's not in
the show we're talking about so I'm not
counting it so we'll move along okay yes
we will be revisiting number 600 so you
get to talk about Tara I'll talk about
Buffy real quick basically pretty much
everything you said and I think in terms
of her self-righteousness I think it's
actually the conversations with dead
people
episode sums her up the most succinctly
where that psychoanalyzing vampire says
oh you have a superiority complex but
you have an inferiority complex about
that and I'm like yeah that's basically
it
she literally knows she's better than
everybody else but she kind of hates
that yeah and she feels she's not worthy
of that so like yeah that's her in a
nutshell that's actually a lot of layers
to play in to deal with and especially
as she as the character grows and
develops over time it's she gets a lot
to do which he pulls it off well but
yeah okay so Tara I
really adore her she's just such a
sweetheart
gonna crush on her in college wouldn't
you um given the other people I crushed
on in college yeah maybe maybe I mean
she she's definitely the sweetest
character in this series and is up there
with like Fred and Kaley in terms of the
Whedon versus yeah he just sweet
characters really well he does yeah he
does um
she really helped real willow realize
who she was and blossom and I know you
say she doesn't have a lot of depth
other than the sweetness but I think she
is very intuitive and really gets people
emotionally because if I mean I recently
watched the back-to-back season for like
who are you and this year's girl or face
possesses her and she's the first one
that knows that something's off with
Buffy without have having ever met Buffy
she's just like I don't think your
friend is who she says she is without
knowing her like how crazy is that like
that'sthat's pretty good she knows she
figures out what willows doing to her
and how she's messing with her mind like
she's very wise and intuitive very quiet
about it and I mean I kind of love how
she develops her self-confidence I I
really like her um she's just so sweet
and God her death oh it's heartbreaking
so I mean like the more heartbreaking it
is the more you know you're connected to
that character mm yeah yeah so I just I
really like her
oh it's very close to number five to
like I'm I I'm pretty much on the fence
line about these two like I'm like I I
think she would have been higher Terra
if she had been in it more and if we had
seen more of that like wiseness and just
a longer story arc okay fair enough so
we're at that we're at the halfway mark
okay so we're at number five
this one is an interesting one for me
I'm gonna have to explain this a little
bit how I did this so ready okay oh yeah
he's not on my list okay
either one nope that's it so this was
the call that I made was whether or not
I was going to rank angel and Angelus
has one character or as two I opted to
rank them as one character mm-hmm
because I do feel that certainly a lot
of the strength of Angelus comes off of
the severity of the heel turn versus
angel I think if we didn't know angel as
well as we did Angeles would not be as
effective a villain as he is and then
later on when we see him grappling with
you know the stuff that he's done having
seen Angeles we have a lot better sense
of what that actually looked like like
in exactly how much damage he did for
how long he did it so I'm thinking if I
split them I would probably maybe put
Angeles as 10 cuz I really did not have
angel but not have angel I do like angel
but he's just too mopey for me he is and
he's who's serious and he's also better
on his own show so much better on his
own show so I would he would definitely
make the top ten on his own show again
he probably wouldn't be the top but he
would definitely go on there and I love
him as a puppet well I mean why yes that
is always causing and here's the thing I
am I actually kind of a group agree with
you because he's higher because I put
them together
so having Angelus tried to angel brought
the whole thing up whereas if I rank the
best villain if I night I in my belief
he is - if I ranked angel by himself he
would bet his best shot would have been
10 but he's huge like you're Angeles
dead he's still he's still a good
character for his function within the
show man Angeles is fine that's a good
villain
I like nothing packs an emotional punch
like Angelus like he devastates not just
Safi but like John is good good stuff
you'll be gained and again the reason I
did tie them together is because I do
think the reason he works as well as he
does is coming off of what we already
knew about angel mm-hmm so that's why
I've got them together so Giles Giles
so I he's great
I he's just I loved his dark edge and I
loved his past as like you know like
kind of a bad boy and everything um he
puts up with so much and you can tell
he's just be funneled by them sometimes
like what why we just wants a cup of tea
and to read a book yeah being said as
the librarian I'm like he's a little
mired in those stereotypes of the stodgy
librarian so we don't love that I really
there I haven't really found any
depictions of librarians anyway yeah and
media my head Canon for that is not that
he stodgy because he's a librarian he's
that stodgy by nature and the Watchers
set him up with his cover story as a
librarian because he fit that in my
study you know okay I'm saying the
Watchers can't think past stereotypes
and that's how they did their cover
story as the Watchers are kind of dumb
collectively as an organization I could
listen to him sing all day
Oh God speaking of like Hera like if
they could just put out and all them
together I think they are my know well
there's other good singers in the mural
episode but they're just in there
they're do wet in the music mode is one
of the underappreciated gems of that
show they just have such gorgeous voices
and yes that that will put him high on
my list I don't fully admit that I like
that he as dodgy as he is and as
confused as he is
by the kids that he's not afraid to
break from the Watchers Council and from
tradition yeah
again that edge and you're wandering
away I'm sorry
he's got great morals but he never comes
off as self-righteous or even really
that self-righteous at all but certainly
not as much as bossy
well he's buffy is a I do it cuz it's
right here Oh Giles is a the greater
good yeah that's true person so they
they come at problems from a different
headspace so okay now before we get to
this I need to explain the number on the
one I'm about to show is wrong because
at the last minute I swapped my three
and four so the one over by that we're
doing number four my card is gonna say
three it's because I swapped these two
at the last minute okay so here we go
[Applause]
spike thunders into this show with so
much swagger and just the epitome of
yeah I don't care I'm just cool by
default we're giving into my like oh
they're so hot I'm just like oh yeah the
hottest characters so I mean he is the
moody vampire as you want it like forget
Twilight like he he's so mistreated and
so in love though and so angsting after
these women who just I I love that he
hates the fact that he falls in love oh
god yeah I love that he wakes up from
that first dream he's like oh god no I I
love how much he hates himself for
feeling feels mm-hmm yeah he really does
and here's why
oh and he's got the best insults like
he's great with other characters and
everything here's why he's not number
two I have a hunch
it's that attempted rape on the boom and
that's why he's not hired for you I
think that's part of why I'm part of it
was also thinking like the one I have it
number four our so I also want to put up
a little bit so it was a combination of
both but that was a factor that was a
factor on the last night I cannot
forgive him for that I don't care if he
does he didn't have a soul at that point
I don't care if he went to get us a
little after I'm still mad at him I
still cannot forgive him he is the
coolest he's very the epitome of swagger
and everything but oh the show worked
really hard to I don't want to say
justify that because I don't think the
show trying to get I think the show
worked very hard to try and mitigate to
try and show that it recognized the
damage of that moment and then mitigate
it for the character I'm not sure they
did enough to pull it off not for me but
they they tried yeah I mean thank God
that she stopped him because then he
would have been yeah that and I will say
the the show has dealt with other issues
of consent because if you look at the
situation where faith in Buffy's bodies
Riley that is questionable as well
though he clearly consents when he
because he's yeah who he consents to is
not who he he yes John Dean said she
freaks out to instantly and was like
this is wrong and everything and like
freaks out and that and obviously the
what willow does to Tara is questionable
as well in terms of that's a little more
than questionable well more than
questionable your bob was right well but
it's not what those are those are things
were not used to seeing in everyday life
those have a semester with people's
minds to don't have a certain detachment
because of the fantastical element
whereas attempted rape is
so that's a real-world problem so that
yeah that that that ends up doing more
damage to the character than that other
stuff does yeah no you're right
yes so I think that's why I
that was a serious end yeah character we
both enjoy we I do I do I like spike a
lot but yeah it's yeah so my next one is
gonna say four it's really my three here
we go oh okay okay so should I go first
cuz mine mine he's on my list okay go
ahead so okay so a lot of what you said
I just oh she's hot lips ever and like
the books so good and leather and like
but she just has such gleeful miss about
saying like she loves it it's such a
great contrast Buffy - Buffy it's a
burden to faith it's a it's a calling
and she just had such great relish in
that like ish love sex like it doesn't
have the hang-ups that Buffy has about
it because of Angelus I'm like I just
thoroughly enjoy her she also has a
great vulnerability to her which you see
even in season three with the mayor you
know they never really do flashbacks for
did we ever get a face no no never not
even once which I think actually I like
better behind I did - you get to guess
about her past and you know it's
horrible and you know no one's loved her
and she gives she says a little bit
about it but you just can imagine it for
yourself I don't think there's any
details that could have given about her
past that would do the job as
effectively as the assumptions you
already make mm-hmm yeah um I you know
her her relationship we talked about
this with the mayor is great how he
latches on to a mess the one chance she
for a father figure and let's let's be
honest she picked a really good villain
her father like he's up there he is up
there like second and my villain list
Angeles um and like wanna see all that
girls should have as much fun as she
does so much fun um she is she's really
great at pointing out Buffy's felt
self-righteousness like she and Spike
are like great at it here's a scene
where she teases spike as Buffy but like
it's still face face character in that
body is really hot and she does have a
great redemption arc you're right and
mainly occurs in Angelus but you start
to see the beginning of it before she
goes to Los Angeles and season 4 this is
the most recent stuff I watched today
she would have this would have been put
up for two months and she would have
kept researching if I hadn't said look
can we just shoot this they already I
would have watched all of the faith
nothing that's not a bad thing to be
clear I'm just saying I mean she thought
in your list you yes um she's also one
of the few characters I enjoyed in the
comics and really remember in the comics
which men I'm gonna count I mean she's
she's got a really good story story arc
and general and I know part of it you're
right is on Angel and that should count
for something but I'm still I'm still
stand by this number three remember your
justifications do not have to be my
justifications if I don't want to fact
that and that's not me saying you aren't
allowed to factor in it you are have
that count not be like no must divorce
that you don't have to these are mine
these are my hangups she's my most she's
the highest rank fun character okay yeah
so yeah so Xander I think like many
people like me and at my age I just
identify with Xander a lot
especially those first couple seasons
you know he has a vague idea of what
cool is
and he knows he wants to be it but he's
just not and he's just never gonna be
I'm like oh that's that's really
familiar yet at the same time it doesn't
become a cringy thing it doesn't become
oh what a loser it becomes I know this
is a good guy who just you know like
most people in high school is unhappy
with what he is surprise surprise
but I I love that in many ways he is the
emotional heart of that team of that
core team of Buffy willow Xander Giles
and I really do feel he is the emotional
heart of that group and I it will always
be one of my favorite things that he
saves willow at the end of season six
okay I'm just gonna say right now you
like my number two and you're just
stealing all my know oh I'll stop there
and let you pick up the rest when you
get win when we get to number two then
what actually so that's what right so
let's just go then number two and you
can pick up everything you said about
him um I just I wouldn't want him as the
best friend he's I mean he's a he is
emotional core it makes sense that
that's what he is for when they build
the beast that goes there the whatever
against Adam like he the emotional core
of the show my gosh like nobody else
could bring willow back from the brink
it had to be him he was the only one
like uh and I recently rewatched the
Zeppo episode and I just love how like I
don't honestly care what's going on with
them and fighting the like monster the
weeks they're saving the world again
what else is new but it's just that he
is you know he's like oh I'm gonna pick
up a girl I'm fighting this bully I'm
saving the school from a bombing by
tricking this bully into disarming it
himself I'm losing my virginity
I'm gonna do all this but not tell them
not because I'm like mad or huffy or
passive aggressive but like just they
have a lot on their plate and they're
saving the world and that is and ER you
know what I can deal with I can deal
with my stuff yeah he's just so I'm
assuming he's sweet he's just so
good-natured he's just and he is really
like gets people emotionally for the
fact that like you know he's supposed to
be kind of doofus II and like he does
get people like I think the one thing
that might count against him for me is I
don't feel they properly justified his
leaving honey at the altar I think they
may not remember that enough I think
they made the decision that that's what
they wanted to have happen but they
didn't properly justify it in the
character I think he's one of those
characters Berg and I have dated these
people where they were are much better
friends than they are boyfriends and I
think that's probably yeah yeah I'll
give you that so you didn't even look at
what my number two was oh I didn't oh we
don't we have different ones okay I know
who your number one is okay okay
but yeah just gonna flow in [ __ ] yeah
this'll this will flow into engine
number ones so yeah I I mean just go
ahead and guess I know she's your number
one so go ahead yeah okay so we can just
babble bot whoa okay first you can
dabble about first of all she was my
crush on that show well yeah she's old
she's so cute and then she comes into
her own and she's like oh okay yeah this
will you agree she has the best story
arc in the whole series um you don't
think that I'm well I'm thinking thing
yo I think as a character overall yes
okay yes I will because that's what
sells me for her among a lot of other
things but like her shoes it's he's also
one of the best because it's really I I
complained about this when I did my
comic book tropes that I thought
hate one of the things that I complained
about was heroes becoming villains and
it's not that is it good it's not that I
inherently have a problem with the idea
it's that it is so rarely properly
justified it just kind of happens here
not and not only is the event traumatic
enough that you buy at the very least
you're going after these three guys for
Lent lessly but they had also laid
enough groundwork in terms of the what
she had been dipping yet that it makes
sense that she goes as bad as she does
so that whole that whole move which is
something I that normally doesn't work
for me they did it right there born now
might be one of my favorite lines in the
whole series born now yeah that one it
didn't count towards my ranking but also
again we might vampire will oh god yeah
oh yeah like oh she is so hot as vampire
will oh I love it normal or gets in the
course and she's like oh look at those
they all thought she was dead she comes
in and they all said how are you hey you
just didn't I'll do a whole bunch of
drugs did you oh she's the cutest she's
all she's adorable
okay but then she does me mature into
she doesn't they don't try and keep her
they don't try and freeze her in
carbonite as cute they let her evolve
I'm seeing go beyond fuzzy hats and less
flowery sweaters yeah but but it all
makes sense it makes sense that from
there she goes to where she does and has
everything happen to her as it does I ya
know I'll give you yes she has the best
character yeah but so so my number one
yeah I figured that was gonna be your
winner number one once I realized that
Willa was here
wait can I say more about Willa okay I
didn't get to say all I want to say that
was like I she's great oh and the thing
is like how
listen Hanigan is so good
she's just when she cries in the series
I cry so hard like she breaks my heart
like no one else she's just good in all
her different forms like she's so
convincing as a bell and thank God she
is a villain in season six because
someone needed to take over from the
trio thank you and she also works off
all the different characters really well
she works really well up spike obviously
off of Xander of Oz like everyone she's
great with uh she you know and you know
she she's a character where she messes
up and she just it makes sense like you
know even when she is the quirky little
girl she does like you know kind of
cheat she she does she on her boyfriend
and kisses her best friend and like you
know figures out her sexuality in
college had this amazing sweet
girlfriend like gets an addiction like
you just feel for her throughout and I
just yeah I just love her I know
favorite like oh she's great yeah I'm
kind of well I I can you thighs with a
little bit I was definitely willow in
high school so Giles go for it I'll let
you take over
you can't just have though that's word I
have an odd affinity for well done
exposition characters in the first place
because expedition done badly is one of
the most boring things in in fiction but
a a if you can have a character and more
importantly in the case of film or
television an actor playing that
character who you never get tired of
hearing speak oh god you know that that
goes a long way
oh that goes a long way to alleviating
the the potential issues with exposition
but so I liked him I liked him from the
beginning but then we get to season two
and we get the first hint of his dark
side when Ethan Rayne shows up and
John's just decks him and it's like whoa
okay hold on a minute and we get these
little glimpses oh he's got a fun
director of this darkness that and it's
an unlike say angel and Angela's or even
Willow and you know where she goes it's
not this something that she's like at
nighttime duality it's not the duality
it is something that is you realize is
always there and what I love about him
is and is that he is a pragmatic hero
which you don't get a lot of pragmatism
is so often a trait given to villains or
at least you know very gray characters
he is undeniably a hero but he is also
pragmatic because and I think the moment
that sums that up best is the finale of
season 5 when they're dealing with glory
and Buffy goes you know to save dawn
into you know but she goes to say God
and you know this guy forget the guys
name but the guy who like shared his
body with glory then Ben yeah I think it
was Ben but you know child goes on you
and she wouldn't kill you because she's
a hero and then he puts his hand over
his mouth and nose and yeah you've done
this she wouldn't do this but it has to
happen so I will do it and he has what
is undoubtedly my favorite all-time
return of a character after an absence
which is in season six after he's been
gone for a bit
willow after absorbing all this dark
energy says there's no force on earth
that could stop me now there's this
blast of energy knocks her to the back
of the shop and there's jaws in the
doorway I'd like to test that theory oh
thank god yeah I'm it
so much I was like gosh they're a hot
mess was gonna ruin the world
Buffy worked at a burger place it's like
I don't even oh I imagine that's when
like Xander left Anya the altar was
seasoned like they were a hot mess they
so needed that man to come back and stay
and like yeah yeah I I just I I always I
will always have an affinity for kind of
the stealth badass and I am yeah I'm in
real life I love oh Anthony story heads
great oh he's got a good eye
I fully respect your choice for and I
respect yours thank you for joining me
so yeah this is it
um you can if you'd like hearing us
together we have a podcast called tough
like a girl where we cover female female
I finish my drink over the course of
this so give me oh you had your drink
with you and also if there's at least
half the members of the team are female
there yes Eleanor Pancho did a couple
team one we have but yeah because we did
lumberjanes and that was the main one
yeah but yeah so we we on the podcast we
talked about graphic novels and trade
collections with female protagonists or
at least teams that are 50% or more
female that's a monthly podcast check
that out if you like also there's a
whole bunch of other links down there
you check those out too if you want one
of them goes to the patreon but but you
know if you don't want to support me in
that way don't sweat it because at the
end of the day folks you are the council
and I just run the meetings occasionally
with help and until next time this
council is adjourned
all right for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]